today Vice President Mike Pence will
travel to the us-mexico border to tour a
migrant detention facility
he says migrants are receiving care that
Americans would be proud of despite a
government watchdog report of turmoil
the trip comes as roundups could deport
thousands of undocumented in
undocumented immigrants starting this
weekend larae avi RI al is at the
facility in Dona Texas where pence is
going Mireya what is the vice president
trying to achieve we know my pants will
be here in South Texas for about six
hours and he will visit the tent
facility that you see behind me here in
Dona Texas in an effort to prove that
the Democrats conditions that they
describe that things are awful inside
that those conditions are inaccurate
those descriptions are inaccurate
meanwhile the Trump administration is
now turning its sights to removing
illegal immigrants living here in the US
illegally while some local leaders are
saying they will not comply and help
we're gonna secure our border on
Thursday Vice President Mike Pence
insisted agents inside detention
facilities are keeping migrants safe
they're providing health care shelter
food sustenance in a way that would make
the American people proud earlier this
month a scathing report by the Office of
the Inspector General detailing squalid
conditions in border patrol facilities
quoted one manager who called the
situation a ticking time bomb last week
we spoke to 22 year old Liliana and her
four day old baby after they were just
released from one of the facilities
I was scared she said there is no place
to shower or have hot meals this is a
completely out-of-control situation
chairman of the Homeland Security
Committee Senator Ron Johnson says
agents are doing everything they can to
keep families safe in overwhelming
conditions border patrol facilities were
never designed for families they
certainly weren't designed for this size
of illegal flow
Pence's visit comes as the Trump
administration also moves to conduct
raids in at least 10 cities to round up
at least 2,000 undocumented immigrants
currently under deportation orders
mayor's in several of those cities are
telling their Police Department's to not
cooperate Chicago is and will always be
a welcoming city that will never
tolerate ice tearing our families apart
some undocumented immigrants are taking
refuge in safe spaces like churches
including this mother of two whose
children are US citizens notathome of
the thing that ano nadia thought we
aren't harming anyone she said were just
mothers seeking a better future for our
children
[Applause]
several Democrats were invited to go on
this tour with the vice president but
none agreed to come here to South Texas
and just a note several ice agents I've
spoken with say that these rates are
something they do on a regular basis the
difference is this weekend you'll see
more resources and more emphasis behind
them Michelle Maria thank you